[Musique]
l'image que j'ai en tête
belges et des images évidemment de la
cérémonie mais pas que en fait j'ai
aussi dans une voiture avec ma fiancée
et mon agent que j'ai depuis depuis le
lycée qui m'a repéré au lycée alors que
je jouais un chien dans une pièce de
théâtre et on est tous les trois dans
une voiture en train d'aller ensuite au
dîner après les césars et du coup j'ai
là quand vous me demandez
instinctivement j'ai un peu cette image
là en tête avec le césar dans la main et
paris qui défilent la nuit le césar du
meilleur acteur est attribué à pierre
niney souviens que j'étais dans une
hallucination absolue et totale
d'entendre mon nom prononcé par juliette
binoche que j'ai regardé dans tant de
films que j'ai admiré dans tant de films
enfin vraiment j'avais une sensation
c'est ce que j'ai essayé de de
bafouiller après d'être des deux a
repris une drogue très forte quoi merci
beaucoup
j'ai l'impression de la sensation d'être
en caméra subjective lie d'arriver dans
une eau de vie joue à juliette binoche
et kirsten stewart me tende un césar
c'était très étrange
waouh les gens se disent parfois et j'ai
rencontré en fait pas mal de gens après
qui m'ont d'iran mais vous savez quand
même un peu vous êtes mis au parfum de
pas du tout quoi vraiment là et ça fait
partie de la magie du truc c'est que ça
n'est ça n'est pas truqué c'est vrai et
du coup la surprise pour moi était
très très réel merci merci aux votants à
tous ceux qui ont voté pour moi
du fond du coeur merci à jalil lespert
qui est là merci jalil et puis
évidemment guillaume gallienne guillaume
qui est l'autre moitié de ce film
l'autre moitié de ce couple de cette
histoire de création cette histoire
d'amour guillaume et baky fatalement du
cou et l'autre moitié de ce césar et
avec guillaume guillaume gallienne en
coulisses en fait je sais plus pour
quelle raison j'ai à quelques mètres de
moi du coup personne ne le voyait mais
pour moi c'était génial qui soit juste à
côté de moi et puis je voulais vraiment
dire un mot pour lui je pensais vraiment
ça quand j'ai dit que c'était c'était
cette récompense elle était séparée en
deux entre bergé saint laurent
c'était un duo tellement tellement à la
fois une quelque chose de merveilleux
dans une espèce de monstre à deux têtes
merci et puis je vais avoir un mot
évidemment pour gaspard avec qui on a eu
une année un peu spéciale tous les deux
la veille au soir
j'ai écrit deux trois petites choses que
j'espérais retrouver si jamais j'avais
la chance de monter sur scène
je savais que je voulais dire un petit
mot pour gaspard ulliel qui avait joué
le même personnage la même année dans un
film un autre film ensuite j'aurai juste
une
un remerciement adressé à tous les
votants qui ont cette année ouvert une
porte au jeune réalisateur au jeune
acteur ne pensez pas que c'est anodin ça
nous touche
en tout cas je vais parler pour moi ça
me touche oui avec sean penn est
rehaussée ronge les vues après
exceptionnels mais il m'a dit des choses
super super gentil ça c'était un des
grands moments de m'asseoir aussi
discuter ensuite avec sean penn alors
merci encore une fois
merci de ce césar merci de se souvenir
et merci aux bienveillant
on joue à ces images j'ai conscience de
me dire à la chance que j'ai eu la
chance qu'on me fasse confiance pour un
rôle aussi beau aussi complexe aussi
ambiguë aussi intéressant à 21 ans je
crois quand on propose de rôles de
livres 5 ans donc je je je réalise plus
maintenant peut-être réalisé pas mais
c'est ce qui c'est ce qui rendait la
chose aussi innocente est belle mais je
ouais j'ai maintenant regardons je dis
moi j'étais vraiment chanceux
non mais ce qui est marrant c'est que le
lendemain j'allais le lendemain j'allais
à los angeles et que du coup moi je suis
quand même arrivé là-bas serge arrive à
l'aéroport c'était le monde avait fait
une brève sur les gagnants des césars
donc j'étais dans le monde j'étais dans
certains journaux ça passait sur les
chaînes de télé et tout donc moi c'est
c'est eh voilà quand j'étais le gars
quoi le gard le gars en france et
j'arrive à l'aéroport air france à
bonjour vous allez bien attendez on va
essayer de vous surclassé un bravo
félicitations étaient machin tu prends
l'avion tu arrives là bas l'emea gens
aux états unis me dise félicitations
c'est génial on a vu il faut absolument
que tu viennes ce soir une soirée pré
oscars y aura tous les réalisateurs tout
le monde et où magie ok pourquoi pas
carrément et toujours j'arrive là-bas
supic sur mon petit nuage quoi mon petit
nuage de poudre d'or de césar et
j'arrive là-bas et je le rappellerai
toujours de mon agent qui me présente à
la au premier groupe de gens où il y
avait christopher nolan et son machin
dans un groupe de gens et 10 à l'ennemi
russe pierre niney france mythe pierre
niney et moi je sais comment je fais les
gens me font à nice et messieurs aya soa
et reprennent leur conversation mais
j'en ai rien à branler et c'était là le
meilleur moyen de garder les pieds sur
terre et de fait de te dire ok tout est
relatif en fait ne t'emballe pas et puis
tu es meilleur acteur vraiment dans
l'hexagone et c'est valable un an et
après c'est plus toi et bien et c'était
c'était c'était super en fait j'étais
dans une super énergie et en même temps
ce truc était très drôle et mama bien
remis en place genre voilà ok d'accord
mais bon c'est bien tout et tout et bien
relatif